we just got the biggest and most
exciting Apple watch leak of all time
for Mark German Apple app is now working
on the huge 10 generation Apple watch
and they're about to give it the iPhone
10 treatment actually no this is going
to be bigger than that ever was and it's
going to include a massive redesign that
I personally can't wait for but it'll
also be so big that it's going to cause
a lot of people to hate it and literally
be upset at Apple and if you have no
idea what I'm talking about Let Me
Explain Mark German's power on
newsletter came out this Sunday and he
revealed that Apple's working on a
thinner casing for the Apple watch x
which is absolutely great we all love
thinner tech devices right well wait
until you see how apple is planning to
reduce the thickness of the Apple watch
apparently the people involved in the
development of new Apple watches
complained about the current sliding
band attachment mechanism saying that it
takes up a considerable amount of space
that could be better filled with a
bigger battery or other components and
yes that's true if those huge voids on
both sides of the Apple watch weren't
there Apple could easily make the watch
much thinner or greatly boost battery
life so guess what apple is gonna do you
know that huge Apple watch band
collection that you or someone you know
has collected over the past few years
which probably costs a collective a
thousand plus dollars or more just for
these unique bands especially Hermes
bands which are insanely expensive well
say goodbye because they're all about to
become useless paperweights yes apple is
working on a brand new attachment system
for the Apple watch 10 and many years
into the future finally ditching the
current system and making current bands
incompatible forever but don't worry
I've been looking through a bunch of
Apple patents and it's clear that apple
is making the right choice unlocking
massive potential that is only possible
with this new attachment system that
will enable electronically connected
Apple watch bands for the first time
ever but before I get into those patents
if you're a fan of Apple products like
the Apple watch you've got to get a
portable battery for charging them on
the go like the 65 watt ambly power bank
from our sponsor basis this thing packs
a ton of battery power for its compact
size precisely 30 000 milliamp hours
which is over nine times more than
what's in Apple's iPhone 14 pro it packs
a total of five outputs including the
main 65 watt USBC PD output which is
perfect for fast charging iPads iPhones
and MacBooks it also has four USB a
ports with three of them running at 15
watts and one up to 30. it comes with a
100 watt USBC Cable in the box and it
includes three inputs to charge urge it
including 60 watt USBC 18 Watts for your
iPhone's lightning cable which is very
handy and even micro USB and for added
convenience it comes with an LED display
so you can always see how much battery
power is left as well as the current
voltage and amperage while charging
basis also has their joystar 91 USBC Hub
which is perfect for Macs and iPads with
85 watt pass-through charging gigabit
Ethernet three USB a ports two 4K hdmis
and two SD card slots including TF and
on top of that basis is also doing a
give it free promotion on their website
so you can find the link to that below
as well as a link to their 30 000
milliamp hour portable battery pack and
their nine in one USBC Hub so go ahead
and use those links and coupon code
tech15 to order yours today with a 15
discount now getting back to the Apple
watch I want to stress something very
important before I get into the those
patents the Apple watch 9 coming next
month is gonna be a nothing Burger of an
update with simply a new S9 chip that's
going to be faster and more efficient
but that's basically it and why is Apple
giving it such a bad update well of
course because they're waiting for the
massive Apple watch 10 redesign so I
fully believe that anyone choosing this
year to finally upgrade their watch is
making a huge mistake those people are
going to be massively disappointed next
year when the new attachment system
comes out with a full Apple watch
redesign newer thinner casing new
finishes new unique electronic bands and
more so whatever you do please don't
upgrade your Apple watch until this
Apple watch 10 comes out next year and
please stop buying Apple watch bands
because they'll be worth nothing and
they're going to be useless I'll even go
a step ahead of that and say if you're
one of those people with a large Apple
watch band collection literally start
selling them today because the longer
you wait the more people are gonna watch
this video and the leaks about the new
band attachment system and they're not
going to want to buy your precious
worthless bands and now with that said
let's jump right into how I believe
these new bands will work and connect
you know that Max I feature on the
latest MacBooks which connects
magnetically while sending power through
these four little pins well I imagine
the new band system will work somewhat
like that because Mark German said the
new band attachment system would be
magnetic and just like every other
magnetic feature Apple has introduced in
the past it's going to work seamlessly
with minimal effort Max A3 for MacBooks
is easy and seamless Max save charging
for the iPhone and Apple watch is
seamless the magnetic magic keyboard for
iPad Pro yes quick and easy the magnetic
charging system for the apple pencil 2
seamless so I believe Apple will make
the new Apple watch band system instant
and seamless as well using very powerful
magnets to make sure that your bands
stay put and your watch doesn't
accidentally get knocked off and I think
it's gonna work great and the benefit of
macsafe style magnets is that it'll of
course save a ton of internal space for
making it even thinner but that's not
the most important part of the whole new
band design the main point is the
electronic contacts that allow the watch
to communicate with brand new futuristic
bands that Apple has been working on for
years and we can actually see them in
Apple's patent filings so let's jump
right into that first of all we have to
start with this patent originally filed
in 2016 that shows a magnetic attachment
system that includes electrical pins on
the band itself with this statement in
the future the watch band may include
active electronic components and example
sensors battery processor Etc that may
inter operate with the supporting
Electronics on the watch body unit there
was even an image showing the watch band
with pins plugging into a MacBook to
recharge almost like it'll literally be
the same connector as Max save 3 on the
MacBook going further here's a pattern
that shows off a new watch band that's
packed with battery cells which is
basically like a battery life extender
for your future Apple watch here is one
that's jam-packed with new types of
sensors for sports athletes or whoever
else enabling new measurements to be
tracked all integrated into your watch
but it gets even crazier here's a patent
that shows a new watch band that comes
with a motorized string system to
automatically tighten to give your band
a better fit and it'll all work from an
app or setting on the Apple watch itself
but that's not all we've had many leaks
about Apple introducing blood pressure
monitoring on the Apple watch so this
special tightening band will be required
to tighten onto your wrist to be able to
accurately measure your blood pressure
like what happened with those sleeves
you put over your arm that inflate to
put pressure on your veins even further
we just got a leak that shows that apple
is researching strange sensors to
improve Apple watch strength workout
tracking that same tightening band can
be used to measure strain by first
tightening up and then measuring the
strain on your tendons on the inside of
your wrist but the biggest feature of
all is something that will also require
these new electronically connected bands
and that's non-invasive blood glucose
and blood alcohol monitoring rockly
photonics invented a new way to measure
blood glucose but it'll likely require
an additional sensor on the other side
of your wrist in addition to the watch
itself and guess what this new
electronic band system will be required
to make something like that work and
there are so many other patents showing
off new ideas and sensors for these
futuristic bands making them so much
more useful than they currently are
right now and apple is going to be the
big winner because they're going to be
selling specific bands for specific use
cases and they are not going to be cheap
Apple's gonna make so much money
especially now that all the current
bands are basically going to be useless
everybody has to restart their
collections so this is a genius move by
Apple so with all that said please hold
off until the Apple watch 10 and sell
your massive band collections right now
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did subscribe above and check out
one of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign